[Music]
morning everyone we start with the news
that the Met police are reviewing
hundreds of cases of alleged sexual
offenses and domestic abuse involving
its own staff that comes after the
serving officer PC David Carrick was
revealed as one of Britain's most
prolific sex offenders after admitting
to dozens of offenses against women
including 24 counts of rape over 18
years
the Metropolitan Police is reviewing
more than 1600 cases of alleged sexual
offense or domestic violence involving
its own officers and staff a total of 1
633 cases involving 1071 officers and
staff are set to be reviewed
so Mark Rowley announced all 45
000 met officers and staff would be
rechecked for previously missed offenses
I was standing by for us outside of
Scotland Yard this morning oh my
goodness me how many bad apples are
there good morning Iva
morning Kay yeah this awful case
involving PC David Carrick will
obviously have huge ramifications for
the met in terms of its vetting and
recruitment process and to that end the
Met has already announced this wholesale
review of all allegations of sexual
offenses and domestic abuse involving
its officers and staff over the last 10
years in a number of cases that involves
is staggering more than sixteen hundred
one thousand six hundred and thirty
three cases involving more than a
thousand officers and staff so clearly
some people have had multiple
allegations made against them these
accusations range from arguments right
up to those serious sexual crimes the
force has said that while these
inquiries are being made into these
historic allegations those people
involved those they they those humans
they concerned well for the most part
remain in post but if anything raises a
red flag or any concerns I'll raise then
their status will be rapidly
reconsidered but alongside that all 45
000 of the Met staff and officers will
be checked again check to make sure no
offending was missed it's a huge
undertaking huge administrative
undertaking that will take a long time
but that's what is clearly needed if
Matt wants to restore the Public's trust
and confidence and smart Rowley the
commissioner himself has already said
that he believes there are more than a
hundred offices hundreds of officers
corrupt officers within the force and
this is an attempt to weed them out now
as we know PC David Carrick nine times
came to the police's attention during
his career after allegations were made
against including allegations of rape
but not once did he face any criminal
sanctions or misconduct hearings this
morning at nine o'clock he will face a
misconduct hearing clearly the case of
not just better late than never but
shutting the stable door long after the
horse has bolted okay either
thing uh
Rory with a former senior met police
officer in just a short time here on Sky
News meantime thousands of teachers in
England and Wales are set to walk out of
classrooms over pay after the largest
education Union reached the threshold
required to take strike action at 20
past I'm going to be speaking to the
education secretary that's Jillian
Keegan
also on the program Royal Mail bosses
are preparing to give evidence to the
commons business committee this morning
we'll have more on that and postal
workers have been striking since August
last year to on due to ongoing disputes
overpay the communications workers union
also called strikes on important days
throughout the festive period both CWU
boss Dave Ward and chief exec of Royal
Mail that's Simon Thompson have spoken
to this program during the Industrial
action in the run-up to Christmas
the company itself is also destroying
Royal Mail as we know it they have no
intention of continuing Royal Mail one
of the most iconic British companies uh
that are that is around they are
destroying it they want to turn it into
just another parcel Courier and I'm
going to say to you today the people who
are running this company have got so
much to answer for the the levels of
harassment and intimidation and threats
that are going on in workplaces every
day would be unacceptable in in any
business and yet it's the leaders of the
company who are doing this to Ordinary
Decent postal workers and we're not
going to put up with this we cannot
accept what they're doing
we have been talking for seven months to
try and get this situation resolved
around change and for the first six
months the union did not engage in those
discussions at all I then offered them
the opportunity of joining me with acas
and I have to say that did eventually
happen and a big thank you to the team
of acas I thought they were professional
and dedicated to try and help us resolve
this situation it took the CWU nearly a
month to take me up on that offer we
then spent three weeks in intensive
talks including weekends which I also
participated in and at the end of that
they rejected our change agenda
completely out of hand
so that was both sides of the dispute
with the postal uh strikes that we've
seen before and indeed after Christmas
both sides speaking to a select
committee of MPS later on today just
after nine o'clock run that to you of
course here on the breakfast show and
police urging people in the southwest of
England to only travel is essential
that's what we're hearing this morning
after reports of more than a hundred
road-related incidents within five hours
the majority was as a result of the
freezing weather conditions meanwhile
the UK Health security agency has issued
a level three uh cold alert that was on
Monday in response to severe winter
weather it's advised people with
pre-existing medical conditions or over
the age of 65 to heat their home to at
least 18 degrees Celsius
Met Office have issued this yellow
warning of snow and remain in place for
parts of the UK and has warned that
treacherous conditions could also lead
to slips and falls on icy surfaces and
urge drivers and cyclists to be aware of
icy patches on untreated roads
let's get more should we Joe standing by
for us this morning hi Joe it's not
looking good is it
it's certainly not I mean it was only
just a couple of days ago we were
looking at these very mild wet and windy
conditions and now of course we're in
the grip of a freeze and certainly
overnight temperatures have dropped
below freezing for just about all of the
country and as low as -8 even minus nine
in some places so of course where you've
got any moisture at all you're going to
find icy stretches at that point
obviously the gritters will have been
out you know attempting to look at the
major routes and highways but you can't
get everywhere and it's it's Little
Country Roads you know with Pavements or
even just patches of tarmac where you're
going to find those uh that ice so you
do need to watch out for that there's
obviously a falling Hazard there the
cold weather is going to stay with us
all day level three alert stays with us
until nine o'clock on Friday morning so
there is yet more to come and of course
anything that moves through this very
cold air is likely to fall asleep or
snow and also likely to turn to ice as
soon as it hits those Sub-Zero
temperatures so certainly this morning
we've got shower was over parts of
Scotland quite a few down the West Coast
as well into Northwestern parts of
England into parts of Wales and then
this feature in the southwest the one
that's caused all the problems it's
still there edging its way now across
that more towards
um Exeter and that is still giving some
snow on its Leading Edge sleet behind
that and rain right down towards the
South and the Southwest so that moves
its way through it's going to take a
while to clear away and then there's
another feature coming into the far
north of Scotland later in the day which
is likely to bring some snow possibly
some blizzard conditions as well okay is
that your dog Joe
it is yes
I think he wants a war I tried yeah
you've probably got time to nip him
around the park before we chat again in
the next hour thanks very much
no the latest unemployment figures have
just been published from the ons should
we find out what they're saying Paul is
standing by for us with the details hey
Paul tell us more
uh morning Kate yes uh figures for from
November for the labor market in uh in
the UK and they show a slight rise in
unemployment up 0.2 to 3.7 and perhaps
uh slightly worrying a reduction in the
number of vacancies in the economy 75
000 fewer jobs being advertised leaving
over a million jobs still out there we
know people have been employers have
been struggling to find staff but this
would indicate fewer jobs being
advertised unemployment Rising that the
slowing economy is starting to bite on
the labor market which has been one of
the the low unemployment rate one of the
very very few crumbs of com comfort for
the economy should say pay is rising
these numbers show that average pay has
Is On The Rise Up by 6.4 in the quarter
to November so the demands of employees
facing Rising inflation at over 10 is
being met by employers but there's a big
gap between the private and the public
sector price private sector pay up 7.2
percent on average while public sector
pay was up just 3.3 percent that of
course fueling this industrial
discontent we're seeing the latest
teachers you've already been discussing
this morning but those pay Rises well
they sound good against inflation over
10 it means in real terms again CPI
Consumer Price inflation real terms
wages are actually 3.8 down so more
money being paid but the real effect of
that in your wallet is a reduction in
the amount of money without another
number uh just to bear in mind as we go
on this morning through the rest of this
week 467
000 working days lost to strike action
in November that's the highest in 12
years 1.6 million working days lost to
strikes just six months June to November
we know there'll be plenty more to come
in the next few months so just to
clarify that half a million days lost to
strikes in November
yes that's right that's the uh these
numbers they are
so he was just so sadly we've lost Paul
we'll come back to him
um shortly but um half and almost half a
million strike days lost in November
goodness now an independent review into
how the murderer Damian Bendel was dealt
with by probation officers has found
multiple failings in their handling of
the case at every stage the 32 year old
was given a whole life order for the
murder of his partner Terry Harris her
two children and their friend in
kilimash in Derbyshire Fraser mode has
more so yeah the calmness of a killer
well I know we just go to prison
obviously again wow what are you doing
something to anyone else yeah well you
don't know there's four people this is
Damian bandel handing himself into
police after the brutal murders of his
partner her two children and one of
their friends he had a history of
violence but at the time of the killings
he was on probation serving a suspended
prison sentence for arson
now a damning reports by his Majesty's
inspectors of probation has highlighted
how the services handling of bendel's
case fell well below the necessary
standard that the risk he posed had been
badly underestimated
we found that at every stage of the
Probation Services assessment and
management of Damien Bendel the quality
of that work was of an unacceptable
standard
bandel was living under curfew with his
girlfriend Terry Harris and her two
children John Paul and Lacey Bennett
despite previous convictions for violent
crime and allegations of domestic abuse
made by a former partner he murdered all
three as well as eleven-year-old Connie
gent who was having a sleepover at the
house
the probation service allowed Bendel to
give this address to the courts as the
place where he would serve out his
five-month curfew without first speaking
to Terry Harris without visiting the
property and without carrying out any
domestic abuse inquiries
the review highlighted the fact that
bandel had previously served three
prison sentences between 2011 and 2019
two for violent robbery one for
assaulting a prison officer it says that
Bendel was incorrectly assessed as
posing a medium risk to the public and a
low risk to Partners and to children in
reality it says he should have been
assessed as being of high risk of
serious harm
pre-census reports for his asking
conviction also failed to include
safeguarding or domestic abuse checks
the failings essentially meant that the
judge who gave bandel the suspended
sentence which allowed him to commit the
murders did not have the full facts
about the risk he posed Fraser Maude Sky
News killer Marsh
still to come on the program for you
this morning as teachers in England and
Wales become the latest to join the wave
of winter strikes speaking for the
education secretary Jillian Keegan in
just a moment
also speaking to the former Scotland
Yard detective superintendent as a
serving police officer amidst dozens of
rapes and sexual offenses
and a quarter to the hour speaking to
Helen Roberts Met Office meteorologist
the weather is going to be terrible
today especially if you're in the
southwest or up into the Wilds of
Scotland more on that to come in just a
moment
a British man has been confirmed among
at least 70 people who were killed in a
plane crash in Nepal the foreign office
says it's supporting the family of Rowan
Callum Crichton who is aboard the yeti
Airlines flight 691 which crashed two
days ago Neville is standing by for us
now it at first it had been thought that
no Brits were on board thought that he
was an Irish National sadly one of the
many that perished on this aircraft
foreign
over 70 bodies have been 70 bodies have
been retrieved from from the crash side
they had to abandon the search and
rescue operations yesterday uh in the
evening because of incremental weather
and the dangerous terrain because the
rescue teams had to raffle down almost
200 meters down into the gorge onto the
riverbed where where some of the
wreckage has has been spawn across the
area now there are 45 parties have been
transferred back to Kathmandu where they
have been will be given to family
members and each home has a tragic story
of their own one is of the co-pilot
who was married to a pilot who died in a
similar sort of plane crash 16 years ago
and there is now a lot of anger and
questions are being raised about the
safety regulations of The Nepalese
aviation industry there is the
treacherous weather the mountainous
regions of Nepal but also not much of
investment into safety and regulations
and and mechanisms being put in place by
The Nepalese aviation industry the Prime
Minister pratanda has ordered a
five-member the committee inquiry into
the into the cause of the crash and they
have to give in
their report within 45 days of this and
by in the meanwhile the the people and
the country are grappling with this
tragedy
okay thanks very much indeed thank you
this is the British man who was killed
sadly lost his life when that plane came
down on Saturday
teachers in England Wells are going to
go on strike wave of winter strike
action Jillian Keegan is the education
secretary with me this morning good
morning and good morning kids on the
program
um how could you avoid these strikes
well we've been doing what we can when I
very first started the job on the 25th
of October I had um you know the first
day I had a letter from all four unions
and it basically said we need an extra
two billion pounds next year and the
year after to pay for these uh increases
in pay and also the cost of living to
help schools with the cost of living so
that was the first challenge I was given
and we did secure that in the Autumn
statement
um so it's deeply disappointing actually
that one of the units is only one has um
you know just scraped over the line to
get
um you know a thing under half the
teachers voted for it but about 50 cents
53 turnout 90 percent voted for it so I
think it's just under half that actually
voted to strike in one Union in one
Union Yes and it will impact on many of
our children did pay come up in your
last meeting when you met with the Neu
because yeah I had the leader the
general secretary and she said that
you'd never even talked about fair when
she came in to see you we talked about
pay we talked about mostly in relation
to the pay review body of next year so
what is happening at the moment is the
submissions that we all put in and
everyone puts a submission into unions
the employers the government they take
lots of other inputs in terms of
recruitment retention what's happening
in other sectors Etc and then they look
at all of that we've got to have that in
by the 27th of January so that's what
we're all working on to make sure that
we can see if we can try and come closer
together when we look at pay for the
next pay review body but Mary bandstead
said and this is what she said we talked
about that education was very important
that teachers are very important and we
talked a bit about inflation and we
counted that wage Rises are causing
inflation but no we didn't talk about
money and we didn't talk about money
either for this year or next year well
what happened is we had a sort of wider
discussion and then the officials who
were going to go through all the line by
line submissions for the 27th followed
up with a meeting on the Friday then
we've got another meeting this week on
Wednesday and there's another meeting
with officials all day did you talk
about money with it we talked about it
in general but we didn't talk we didn't
go through line by line of the
submission because they were doing they
were starting to do that with the
officials but we talked about you know
the the principles of what the do you
think it would have been important to
talk about money and potentially you
could have fended off this strike well
you know what we've done in terms of
money is get the budget to pay for the
independent pay-per-view bodies and one
thing that's important when you look at
because there's a lot of information on
pay so there's a five percent rise for
experienced teachers and 8.9 rise for
new teachers that's on the bands the way
a lot of public sector pay works is you
then get progression within the bands so
if you actually look at almost every
newly qualified teacher and about 40 of
experienced teachers will actually be
getting up to 15.9 percent because it
will also include the progression award
as well they get either for promotion or
for progression over time and then of
course you've got other benefits as well
so it is
um you know an offer that the
independent pay review body has put
together it's a lot higher than we put
in it's a lot higher than schools
budgeted but you're an education
secretary the unions come in to see you
why don't you talk about money well we
talk about money but they're saying that
you didn't
well they also said I only met with them
for 45 minutes I was with them an hour
and 10 minutes um but but we did talk
about money but we did it wrong to say
that we didn't negotiate the pay that's
not what we're there to do we didn't
negotiate pay but what we did do was
talk about some of the challenges uh
workload challenges as well we talked
about and we we've gone through for next
year and we will by now they will have
gone through but there's a I think it's
a six hour meeting that's scheduled on
Friday to go through line by line so
she's being disingenuous to say that she
came up and you wouldn't talk about
money
um I mean you know we talked about money
we talked about workload actually the
number one reason teachers leave
um and the retention rates are actually
the second lowest actually the numbers
for last year since 2010 at the rate
level but the the you know the number
one reason teachers leave is workload
and flexibility they want more
flexibility job shares being able to do
part-time that kind of thing so so
they're the things that we really need
to focus on teachers are doing a
brilliant job they're helping our kids
catch up from the pandemic obviously
they've done delivered now about three
million catch-up lessons and tutoring
and they're doing the most amazing job
but we need children in school now
luckily obviously the head teachers
unions
um one of the teachers unions and the
teaching assistant unions have not voted
for strike action so it's only one of
the teachers unions that has and we
issue guidance last night to head
teachers to try and uh well hopefully we
can keep as many schools open as
possible
I mean almost what's the message to a
mom on a zero hours contract who has to
take time off work because she can't
send her child to school because it's
shot it's deeply disappointing I am very
disappointed it's you know I'm
disappointed in the one Union that has
decided to go on strike our children
don't deserve it to be honest we do need
to keep teachers and children in school
and and I will work with you know you
don't need to strike to get my attention
I will meet with people I'll be as
constructive as possible but we do need
to be fair and and the the number one
thing we need to do is tattle inflation
I've said that to you before there's no
point what we need to do is halve
inflation that's obviously what what
we've said will do and go be further
Beyond you know more than that okay talk
to me about the gender reform uh Bill
Nicholas sturgeon said the decision by
Rishi soon act to block Scotland's
gender Reform Bill is a full frontal
attack on our democratically elected
Scottish Parliament and its ability to
make its own decisions on devolved
matters what do you think
um well I wouldn't agree with that I
mean the Scotland act deliberately was
set up with this power in it and I think
it was set up about 25 years ago
anticipating that there could be times
when legislation uh when it looked a bit
messy or there was legislation that
could potentially be competing and it
was set up I mean it was legislation
written by a labor government voted for
by the SMP so everybody agreed on the
the Scotland Act and the structure of it
and the fact that there would be this
power and when it was to be used and
obviously what we can't have is um you
know a lack of clarity in law in terms
of you know gender gender recognition
having two sort of schemes in place
across Great Britain so that's but I
don't understand those comments because
it was something they voted for it was
deliberately designed in the Scotland
act to help us navigate whether where
um any of these sort of difficulties or
things that were less clear would you be
content for children in your schools at
16 to be able to say that they wanted to
change their gender and be able to do
that we have to be very sensitive to
Children you know it's not it's not we
are actually going to publish some
guidance and consult because it is a
very tricky area to get right to get it
has to be age-appropriate and but
children have to be supported as well so
I think what would you think 16 is too
young
um well I mean the the key thing will be
to have that discussion through the
consultation but what do you think
um no I don't actually I think 16 you
know I was working at 16. I was paying
tax at 16. I was could make decisions
for myself at 16.
um but you know it's not really about
what I think it's how we make sure we
get that right balance of supporting
children but also making sure that what
they're getting taught in schools is age
appropriate um I'm sure you've got a
view on this how can we have faith in
our police force when one of them has
just admitted to 49 charges including 24
rapes it's unbelievable it's really
shocking and appalling case and and
obviously the first thoughts are to the
victims many victims and their families
um and yeah it's really deeply shocking
actually what should they might be doing
about it well I think they are they I
mean obviously the matters come out and
they've apologized they've said they've
done a lot in terms of their vetting
procedures there's more they're doing I
think they've referred themselves to
this case to the independent police
organization as well but clearly they
they've got some work to do they do it's
really really important that we have
that trust in our police and of course
you know how high sort of profile cases
like this or Wayne cousins does damage
that and so I think the the police have
more to do and the Met police have said
that they're going to be doing that okay
um it's good to talk to you thanks very
much today for taking the time thank you
morning thank you
first teacher strike we are expecting on
the 1st of February unless the talks
planned for tomorrow yields something
let's wait and see on that one let's see
what the papers are saying this morning
should we the Metro leads with the fall
out after are serving metropolitan
police officer just talking about that
with the education secretary David
Carrick admitted committing 49 offenses
including 24 counts of rape it's also
the main story for the Guardian
newspaper the mirror is saying that the
force had nine chances to stop David
Carrick but fail to act every time the
eye reports that around 800 met officers
are under investigation for alleged
sexual and domestic abuse the male puts
that figure out closer to 1600 in other
news the times focused on the new round
of teacher strikes announced first one
as I said first of February saying it
will hit millions of pupils
Tamara's here morning oops morning Kay
well Jillian Keegan says that she met
with union leaders for over an hour but
I didn't come to a resolution she said
they did talk money they did talk money
but not money this year which is what
the teachers want they talked about next
year's pay review they talked about the
issue of pay in general but she said
they didn't negotiate on this year
because the government's view is that
they offered the teachers five percent
rise which is above what they've had in
many previous years and for the newest
lowest paid teachers it was up to over
eight percent so they're saying that
they were given a generous pay rise it's
not to say that they won't be struggling
with the cost of living like everybody
else is but they've said that what the
National Education Union have asked for
12 is far too much so it doesn't sound
like um they put a pay rather like with
the nurse's dispute it's not like they
want to talk about this year's pay they
are looking at the pay review process
for next year which will the government
will submit evidence for to come in in
April all and I think there's also
interestingly talking to people in
government they're quite Keen to say
that the teachers for example had a more
generous pay rise last year than for
example the nurses did so they're quite
Keen to to send these disputes should be
treated differently but parents looking
at this will think seven days
potentially if schools being closed in
England and Wales return to online
learning all the difficulties of the
pandemic all the difficulties with child
care and getting to work on those days
and thinking is the government should
the government have perhaps done more
yeah what I don't understand is Mary
Barrister the General Secretary of the
EU the National Education news exactly
where you are exactly where the the
Secretary of State for Education was
sitting just a moment ago she said they
didn't talk about pay for this year or
next year and the education secretary is
saying they did also dispute on how long
the meeting lasted whether it was
actually a friendly meeting or not I
think for the unions the whole dispute
hinges on whether they're talking about
this year's pay the government have
effectively ruled out out raising public
sector pay this year and any kind of
one-off payment to make up the shortfall
there's also a question of whether any
pay rise above what's already been
negotiated would come out of existing
budget so schools would have to cut
costs in other ways the unions say they
shouldn't have to and the government
should just put in more money over and
above that the government clearly are
reluctant to give in on this and I think
they're just going to let these these
strikes go ahead there are more talks
with the unions I'm not Julian Keegan
tomorrow
um but it doesn't sound as if what they
want is going to be on the table no it
certainly doesn't does it um let's see
we get two accounts of what happened
after that meeting let's see for now
tomorrow thank you tomorrow's take of
course at uh nine o'clock yeah thank you
also talking about gender identity with
the minister the government has said it
will block gender recognition
legislation that's been passed in
Scotland the law which was passed in
December makes it easier for people to
change their gender without needing to
be diagnosed with gender dysphoria you
have to deck I spoke to trans campaigner
Ellie gomisor before the decision was
announced
can you when you are 16 years old
know that
this sort of decision that will change
your life forever is the right one I
think you absolutely can I mean I
certainly did I didn't come out until I
was 18. but I think I always knew that I
was trans actually there's so many uh
young trans kids who've transitioned you
know some of them at Primary School
they've lived you know the vast majority
of their lives by the time that they're
16 and that their new gender what's
really important when we're talking
about this particular bill is that all
it is is about updating your birth
certificate that's all that the gender
recognition certificate does
Amanda standing by for is now um Amanda
why has Rishi sunak decided to overrule
Nicola sturgeon
well this is a decision which is highly
controversial being described by some as
the nuclear option the first time in 25
years of devolution that the Westminster
government have used this power to
overall a law approved by the Scottish
Parliament now the gender recognition
Reform Act makes it easier for people to
change their gender without the need for
a medical diagnosis and reduces the age
at which you can start that process of
applying for a certificate from the age
of 18 to the age of 16. now the Scottish
secretary Alistair Jack was very careful
in his wording in making this
announcement yesterday for all the
ideological divides over this question
insisting that this was a decision taken
after legal advice on basically for
administrative reasons because of the
impact this legislation in Scotland
would have on uk-wide equalities
legislation with potential problems in
terms of Prisons Schools
benefits as well because people who've
changed their gender in Scotland
wouldn't necessarily have changed their
legal gender in the rest of the UK also
concerns about the impact on same-sex
places obviously the Scottish government
extremely angry about being overwritten
by the UK authorities legal action is
looking likely a very different tone
from Rishi sunax charm offensive we saw
in Scotland last week
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on Sky News
let's get more now on the accelerated
misconduct hearing for PC David Carrick
which will take place later this morning
after the serving metropolitan police
officer yesterday admitted to dozens of
offenses against women including 24
counts of rape over 18 years it sparked
calls for another culture change in
policing let's talk about it should we
form a Scotland Yard detective
superintendent shabnam Chaudhary is with
us now hi good morning how surprised
were you
uh honestly it was absolutely shocking
uh shocking to hear of the allegations
uh the fact that he'd come to notice at
least nine previous occasions for
misconduct matters for domestic abuse
for harassment and all of those were not
either investigated or no further action
taken no criminal action taken against
him which allowed him to continue for 17
years to violently rape and abuse 12
females
I suppose one of the arguments might be
that none of those involved wanted to
press charges but that's not good enough
it's not good enough because we have
victims that can we have victimless
prosecutions you've got to look at the
evidence and I think the opportunities
particularly within policing when you
are an officer who hold the power within
office then you have a higher bar of
professionalism so really they should
have been looked into they're a catalog
of incidents and for some reason the
Metropolitan Police didn't seem to join
up the dots didn't seem to work out I
know that officers get relentlessly
pursued for misconduct matters for much
lesser matters and I'm not saying that
that's wrong the fact is when you've got
an officer who's been subjected or been
accused of these kind of offenses and he
slips through the net and let's not
forget he was also vetted on two
separate occasions knowing that these
allegations were in the background
somewhere another 1600 allegations of
officers and and staff that work for the
Met what's wrong with the Met
well I've tried to look at the positive
side of that because
um Sir Mark Rowley has introduced this
hotline no it may be that this hotline
that the public can call into is the
commissioner the commissioner raily
apologies yeah uh it may be that that
may have increased the numbers of
offices or the fact is that the Met are
now really seriously looking at the
allegations that are coming in and
actually investigating them properly and
more robustly
um what's he going to do
is the jury's Delight I know that Mark
has only been in post um a short time
but he's going to have to root out these
bad apples quickly well he's going to
have to root out the bad apples very
quickly and let's be honest I've heard
this all before it's early days
um I'm I'm liking what I'm hearing many
people are liking what they're hearing
but actions speak louder than words and
I think the next year will be will
determine how he's actually doing let's
not forget the Met are still in special
measures they've got to come out of
special measures they've got to root out
the rotten apples within policing that
is going to take time he's got to change
the culture of the organization that is
also going to take time reminders of
your experience with the Met
fantastic experiences but also some very
very challenging experiences subjected
to race for throughout my career for
being a whistleblower in my early days
and I know that the the impact that can
have on officers who do fear speaking
out I spoke out that followed me for the
rest of my entire service and it did
have an impact on me but in other
respects I had a really fantastic
amazing career
Carrick
um its thought there are probably other
victims out there too scared to come
forward if you read what he did to some
of these women you can see why locking
them under stairs um urinating on them
telling them that they belonged to him
what would you say to other women who
feel that they have been abused by him
but have been reluctant so far to come
forward please come forward you know I
know that the Trust In The Met place is
broken but
this is about the victims this is about
the victims getting Justice and I urge
any female to still try and put their
faith in police and try and come forward
and Report any allegations of abuse
sexual abuse violence because the fact
is many of these some of these will
result in fatalities if they don't get
the right support out there what would
you say to young people who had been
considering I've got a friend who's just
become a detective in the match I often
think about her when these sort of
things happen
um she it very much enjoys her job but
you know this is a stain on the
Metropolitan Police why should other
young people come forward and join the
Met look it is a good career but you've
got to be part of that change if you
want to see that change I've got two
nephews I've got a third nephew who's
now going through the vetting process I
would never stop them or try to
discourage them from joining because I
want them to make a difference within
policing you need an organization that
represents a communities itself that
includes females people of all different
backgrounds so that policing can be
better so that people can have that
trust and confidence for the
organizations across the UK to be able
to report to investigate crimes and to
to make communities safer basically 45
000 officers I think in the match at the
moment they're all going to be vetted
again how long is that going to take
that's going to take a long time okay
because the fact is you know this
vetting process is that they have are
not fit for purpose Carrick got through
in 2017 it wasn't robust enough the Mets
saying they have put some changes in
place in order for those officers that
do come to notice to be considered for
re-veting but the fact is when you've
got a backlog of officers who have been
in for years and years and years and
have probably done all sorts of things
on all sorts of social media networks
you see what goes on with Anonymous
police officers with the way that police
officers behave on social media which
means or to indicate to me there are
some real issues within policing and to
that end you want a full inquiry
apparently into the met and how this
case was allowed to happen what sort of
inquiry are you talking about judicial
inquiry what's through inquiry what I
think would you like to be a public
inquiry in the same way that they had
the Stephen Lawrence inquiry because it
needs to be statutory the fact is this
individual passed through the net he
raped 12 women over a period of 17 years
and unfortunately I hate to say that the
Met police allowed that to happen
thank you for joining us
um I appreciate you taking the time to
join us this morning to share your
experiences and thoughts thank you thank
you bear with me one second if you would
meantime the head of the UK Army has
said that sending tanks and artillery
guns to Ukraine to bolster the country's
war effort will leave the British army
weaker it comes after the defense
secretary confirmed to MPS that the UK
will send 14 Challenger 2 tanks to
Ukraine here's Deborah Haynes with more
British tanks will soon be rolling into
battle against Russian forces in Ukraine
a landmark moment and a major boost to
Ukrainian Firepower along with British
artillery guns and ammunition the
defense secretary announced the details
in Parliament today's package is an
important increase to Ukraine's
capabilities
it means they can go from existing to
expelling Russian forces from Ukrainian
soil
but back on British
British is looking increasingly feeble
the Army already had a shortage of tanks
and artillery all in need of an upgrade
now a good chunk of that is either in
Ukraine or heading there
in a sign of the gravity of the
situation the head of the army made this
Frank admission to his troops in an
internal video message
Sky News has seen a copy of the
transcript
giving away these capabilities will
leave us temporarily weaker as an army
there's no denying it but ensuring
Russia's defeat in Ukraine makes us
safer and as a leading member of NATO
the world's most powerful defensive
Alliance we are protected by the
principle of collective defense
General Sir Patrick Saunders also
stressed the need to modernize the Army
in comments that appeared designed to
put pressure on the new prime minister
for more funds it'll be pointless saying
that the British army could go and fight
against Russia we have next no artillery
next to no tanks next no uh usable
combat vehicles
um you would be sending troops into
Harm's Way where they would suffer
as well as shock the world Russia's
invasion of Ukraine has demonstrated the
need for strong defenses it's a lesson
the UK surely can't afford to ignore
debraham Sky News
a number of people killed in the Russian
strike in the Ukrainian city of danipro
has risen to 40. Vladimir zielinski has
called for more support from allies
saying the attack emphasizes how
important it is to coordinate efforts
and that the UK is sending tanks is a
good example of that
what happened in denipro the fact that
Russia is preparing a new attempt to
seize the initiative in the war the fact
that the nature of the fighting and the
front requires new Solutions and defense
supply all this only emphasizes how
important it is to coordinate our
efforts of all members of the defense
Coalition of Ukraine and freedom as well
as speed up decision-making
today is a good example from Great
Britain a new defense Aid package has
been announced just what is needed tanks
other armored vehicles artillery what we
discussed with the prime minister
foreign
Spacey has picked up a Lifetime
Achievement Award in Italy just days
after appearing in a UK Court to deny
allegations of sexual assault in his
first official speaking engagement since
the sexual assault allegations came to
light the 63 year old visited the city
of Turin where he was honored with an
award for contributing to the growth of
Cinema the two-time Academy Award winner
taught a master class before introducing
the 1999 film American Beauty which he
starred in uh Kevin Spacey is scheduled
to go on trial in London in June
now forecasters say days of rain and
flood will be followed by snow and ice
as temperatures reach freezing
conditions it comes as police warn
people in the southwest of England to
only travel if absolutely essential
joining us now is Helen Roberts
meteorologist at the Met Office hi Helen
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program this morning how bad is it
how bad is it going to get
yes as you say we have seen some
significant snow across parts of
Southwest England overnight as well as
many other parts of the country as well
particularly Scotland and especially
above 100 meters or so where there is
significant snow likely to be more over
the coming days and the warnings that we
have in Force at the moment they're
likely to change so do keep an eye they
could be updated or even escalated at
any time but we're looking at snow and
ice quite widely across much of the UK
particularly areas away from from the
far inland parts of the country
okay what's causing this wave of bad
weather
well it's as with most of our weather
it's all down to the position of the jet
stream uh we are very much on the cold
side of that at the moment uh the reason
for the snow in Southwest England last
night was a small area of low pressure
that tracked across the country but
across much of the UK we have a
Northerly winds Direction which is cold
and it's bringing those snow showers
those wintry showers a mix of of sleet
and snow quite widely across the UK but
particularly across Northern parts and
coastal areas
um which areas should we get enough
flood barriers ready
interesting question so at the moment
most of our precipitation will be
falling as snow so not too much of an
issue for the time being but later in
the week and more especially into the
weekend we do start to see a return of
rainfall and and as you imply um there's
a lot of very saturated ground across
the country at the moment so that's one
we're keeping an eye on when we start to
see milder conditions returning and a
more Westerly regime which is likely to
bring some rain in from the west through
the course of the weekend and into the
early part of next week so that's
certainly one that we'll be keeping an
eye on can we blame global warming for
this
uh that's that's a really interesting
question
um probably not directly for this
particular uh weather setup but it is
something that we look closely at at the
Met Office
um we have a science called event
attribution where we uh assess whether a
particular weather event is more likely
or less likely because of climate change
and that's that's a new and developing
science I would imagine for this
particular event probably not
um as you would imagine it tends to be
more the the warming and the extreme
events that that are attributable to
climate change
and I've been reading up about El Nino
and La Nina I think that's how I
pronounce them both
um that's right yeah yeah so um they are
apparently uh likely to cause us
um an extreme heat warning this year
tell me a bit more about that
so these are
um Global drivers as they're often known
um Global because they can influence the
weather across the globe
um but the the El Nino and La Nina
originate in the Pacific
um and they can cause different impacts
in different parts of of the of the
world and in the UK um so we're in La
Nina at the moment
um and that can often mean that we will
see wetter weather towards the end of
winter so that again is something we're
keeping a close eye on there is the
potential for some some wet and stormy
and probably quite mild weather later
this winter
um obviously that doesn't also exclude
the potential for further cold snaps as
well but that is is the trend that we're
looking at um so yeah one that we're
keeping an eye on okay but more pressing
matters of course what's happening with
the weather today and for the rest of
the week we know that there's some
problems with ice and snow
what would you suggest people need to do
over the next few days what would you do
if you were in the southwest of England
or indeed if you were up in the Wilds of
Scotland
I would certainly leave extra time for
and you travel if you're traveling by
car then just take a few extra bits and
pieces with you make sure you have some
water perhaps a hot drink a coat a
blanket maybe even a snow shovel
particularly if you're in Scotland just
be extra prepared and extra vigilant do
keep an eye on the forecasts and
warnings and if you're traveling by
public transport then then do just allow
a little bit of extra time and check
before you go
sorry are we all going to see snow
no not all of us many Inland areas so
parts of the Midlands for example may
not see any of these snow showers at all
but they could affect just about
anywhere it's just that they're more
likely in the north and around more
coastal areas and um looking a little
bit further forward
um are we going to have a bit of winter
well um so we're halfway through winter
at the moment and so far it's been on
the mild side with the exception of the
first two weeks of December this is a
fairly uh transitory blip in the
temperatures as I said we will start to
return to something nearer normal as we
head through the course of the weekend
um we can't rule out further colder
snaps
um but but the trend is probably for
something milder than average rather
than colder than average overall okay
good to talk to you thanks for your
expertise much appreciated thank you
thanks
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet uh the right half there you
go over there uh that shows um what
we're using uh with our power mix
currently using a bit of coal actually
today we haven't normally seen that um
perhaps illustrates just how cold it is
and then here on the left hand side that
shows how much the planet has increased
in temperature since 1880 and also the
CO2 emissions in millions of tons all
real-time dashboard
now Queen has been voted 2022's
children's word of the year the Oxford
University press asked more than 4 000
children aged 6 to 14 what words they
felt had been important to them 46 chose
queen as their number one following the
death of her majesty and the earlier
celebration of course of the Platinum
Jubilee
and the Royal Mint has unveiled its
first uh bullion coin with the portrait
of King Charles the king's Effigy will
appear on the 2023 volume Britannia gold
coin marking a new chapter for the Royal
Mint and whose birthday do you think it
is today
Michelle Obama she is celebrating her
59th birthday today many many happy
returns to her